Holmes swept into the sea others
pummeled to Pieces Fiona left a swath of
Destruction and debris across Eastern
Canada no deaths were reported but
residents recall a sleepless night
hoping their homes would hold up against
hurricane force winds
the worst type damage I've ever seen
here I've never seen so many trees
uprooted and had damaged we stayed
downstairs because the whole house was
shaken and watched out the window and
listened to the sounds and hearing the
bang here and bang there and wondering
what what it was
crews are rushing to fix roads and
restore power which may take days in
some areas Canada's prime minister
deployed the military to help
this is an all hands on deck effort and
I know that our Canadian Armed Forces
will rise to the challenge as they
always do the Canadian Hurricane Center
says it recorded the country's lowest
barometric pressure on record during
Fiona
we know that the climate is changing for
sure we're seeing you know look around
the world you're seeing fires storms
certainly this is a historic storm for
this province there's no question about
that meanwhile life continued in the
middle of the storm this couple still
went through with their wedding
reception we got it done because we had
we had the people here that we wanted
here so we just decided we're just going
to do it
it will take days to calculate the full
scale of Fiona's damage and weeks more
for life to return to normal
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera